[Music]
joining me today is the first investor
in Bitcoin comm blockchain comm and
several other cryptocurrency websites
who's also a libertarian an
individualist and a peace advocate Roger
Vere welcome to the Rubin report thanks
for having me on I was gonna savor but
when I did a little research and it's
actually veer even though most people
savor this would lead one to getting
into cryptocurrency wouldn't it that's
the exact reason that it's very easy to
see that that's why I would get into
cryptocurrency yeah alright I am looking
forward to doing this conversation cuz
as I mentioned to you briefly before we
started for about two years or so I've
sort of been kind of looking into this
world a lot of my audience the
libertarian side of my audience of
course is very much into Bitcoin so I
think probably for the first half of
this we have to just do do 101 stuff are
you ready to have your your thinking cap
on you bet all right for someone that's
watching this Bitcoin they have no idea
what that means they think it has some
connotation to Super Mario you know
punching the question mark and getting
coins out of this thing which makes some
sense I guess at some level what the
hell is Bitcoin
so Bitcoin is thanks to the invention of
Bitcoin for the very first time in the
entire history of the world any human
being can now send and receive any
amount of money with any other human
being
anywhere on the planet instantly
basically for free you don't have to get
permission from a bank you don't have to
get permission from the corporation you
don't have to get permission from a
government not only do you not have to
get their permission it's impossible for
any of those entities to stop it so you
can now send money from from here in LA
to Tomas Cao instantly just like that
for a less than a penny and there's
nothing that the Russian government can
do there's nothing that the Chinese
government can do there's nothing that
the American government can do so if you
think that it's a good thing that people
have control of their own money and
they're not susceptible to things like
we had happened in Cyprus a few years
back where the government just came in
and said okay we're going to take I
think it was a third of it everybody's
money in their bank accounts if you
think things like that are bad you
should love Bitcoin and even if you
haven't used Bitcoin yet it
might sound complicated and difficult
but think of it like email if I sat here
trying to explain to you how email
worked it would sound really hard and
confusing and how could anybody figure
out how to do this sort of thing but
once you've used email it's not hard
it's easy you just type in the person's
email address and you send them a
message
bitcoins the same way you just paste
copy and paste their Bitcoin address and
you send them some money yeah and so the
best advice I can give to anybody that's
new to Bitcoin don't be afraid of it go
on the internet and get a Bitcoin wallet
and give it a try it's really really
easy to use once you've actually used it
yeah I mentioned to you that we take
donations at Rubin report.com slash
donate and we take Bitcoin donations we
didn't do it for awhile and we had all
these people saying why aren't you doing
it you're missing a great opportunity
here so we did it we've about I think
around two and a half Bitcoin right now
and I've seen it kind of you know go up
and you can't really watch it every
though at least from where I sit you
can't watch it every day because you'd
start going crazy it's just like
watching stocks every day but what is it
what actually is it so I get the ease of
transfer and I want to talk to you about
why some governments kind of embrace it
more and some really or against it and
all that stuff but like people that's
what people know like what like gold we
know what gold is it's a thing you can
put it in your hand what actually is
Bitcoin
so with traditional money's that people
are used to using like the dollar or the
Euro or traditional payment networks
like PayPal or Visa or MasterCard all of
these things have one ledger that keeps
track of for example PayPal they have a
ledger at the PayPal world headquarters
and maybe a couple of backups they keep
track of how many dollars you have in
your account and how many dollars I have
in my account and when I transfer some
PayPal dollars from my account to your
account they update their ledger but
because they're the ones that are in
charge of that ledger and keeping track
of that ledger at any point they can
reverse the transaction I made to you
they can take all the money out of your
account they can take all the money out
of my account the IRS can go to them and
say take the money out of both of our
accounts anything can happen at any time
that's beyond our control even though we
like to think of the money that's in our
PayPal account as our money but in
reality we have to trust PayPal to hold
it because PayPal has that one ledger
they're at the mercy of you know their
higher-ups which are the government
people with Bitcoin instead of there
being one ledger that keeps track of who
has how many bitcoins and what
there's a copy of this ledger but it's
on everybody's computer around the world
that's running a copy of the Bitcoin
full node software and so instead of
there being you know one or two or three
copies there's a more than a hundred
thousand copies of this ledger around
the world and those a hundred thousand
copies of the letter all stay in sync
with one another and those Ledger's are
in you know every country around the
world so let's say I send some money to
you be a Bitcoin for something that a
government doesn't like there's no
Bitcoin company that they can call
there's no Bitcoin server that they can
unplug all they could do is arrest the
two of us but that doesn't stop the
Bitcoin network as a whole it keeps
right on going so the real powerful
invention of Bitcoin is this ledger
that's not on any one computer the
ledger is distributed across the entire
planet so there's no single place that
anybody could go to to stop or modify it
or unplug it or turn it off and so for
me that's what's so exciting about
Bitcoin is the only way to stop it would
be to turn off the entire internet in
the entire world and keep it turned off
and in 2017 I don't think that's a very
likely proposition I suspect there's
some bad guys there's got to be an evil
guy somewhere twirling his mustache code
we can shut off the entire internet
right
maybe but hopefully not and hopefully we
can build even more technologies to
prevent bad people from turning off the
whole world's Internet and we saw what
happened when they tried in in Turkey
previously they turned off the internet
we just within the country and people
were instantly rioting in the streets
and uh it led to an entire revolution in
that country and I suspect that what
happened in a lot of countries around
the world if they tried to turn off the
internet completely okay so I'm with you
I understand that basically the ledger
the information the true information of
who has what and when they have it and
all of that I understand that when
people say we're we're mining for
Bitcoin what does that actually mean
so this ledger that's all across the
entire world gets updated once on
average every ten minutes but it's who
gets to decide who gets to make that
update so the way that problem was
solved is all these people are doing
these really complicated math problems
and the only way to find the answer to
this maths problem is just to guess and
you have to guess over and over and over
again so these Bitcoin mining machines
are guessing millions of times a second
or even more than that and when they
find the
you ever machine and there's you know
millions of these around the world
whichever machine finds the right answer
to this math problem is then the one
that's designated to be able to make the
next update to this worldwide Bitcoin
ledger so then all these different nodes
around the world make their update and
boom the transactions at the networks at
the next state and then all the
computers start trying to guess again
but the benefit of finding the right
answer to this solution is at the moment
you get 12 and a half bitcoins if your
computer is the one that finds the right
solution and twelve and a half bitcoins
at the moment is worth what like 80
$80,000 or so yeah oh I should mention
by the way that we're taping this
probably about two weeks before it's
gonna air so anything we say related to
the specific numbers I don't want people
to take out of context they got here
doesn't know what he's talking about
because there was 2.4 it you know ok and
it and almost certainly by the time this
airs it'll be something like that what I
said so basically even if we were doing
this live right now things would be
changing on the fly I'd have to check
live on the on the phone to see what the
current price is to figure it out and
and Bitcoin is volatile but from my
point of view I want to be exposed to as
much of that volatility as I possibly
can because Bitcoin allows you to send
and receive any amount of money with
anyone anywhere in the world basically
for free and there's nothing anybody
could do to stop it and there's a
limited supply a Bitcoin there will
never ever ever be more than 21 million
bitcoins so if you stop so how does that
work exactly because that's oh I've
heard that so they'll never be more than
21 you've got all these computers that
are constantly working to get the next
solution to the mathematical equation so
how is there a finite number of so if
one of these come if one of these
computers decided to give itself more
than the 12 and a half bitcoins that are
supposed to be allocated all the other
computers will reject that and say no
that's not part of the rules of the game
that it's in our software code so any
computer that deviates from that their
transactions and whatever they're trying
to do just gets rejected and ignored by
the rest of the network so right from
day one it was programmed into the
software code that there wouldn't be
more than 21 million bitcoins but those
are released over time so half of the
remaining bitcoins are released every
four years so in the first four years of
bitcoins Bitcoin ten and a half million
coins were released in the next four
years half of that in the next four
years half of that and it drops by by
half every four years so what year will
they all officially we have more than a
hundred years until the
the bitcoins are released out into the
public so uh you know it's that's not a
pressing problem at the moment but uh
right what would even I mean we don't
have to go too far down that since it's
a hundred years from now but what would
happen when we hit when we hit the point
that they're all out there does that
somehow drastically change the way the
game is played well the idea is that by
that point people that are doing the
quant transactions even if they're
paying a fraction of a penny per Bitcoin
transaction of people are doing billions
of transactions per day those fees of a
fraction of a penny per transaction will
incentivize the miners to continue
mining and we have a hundred and
something years to find out to figure
that out yeah I suspect there will be
some other excuse yeah there's more
pressing problems than that one at the
moment sure right okay so how so it
sounds to me that it's incredibly secure
right can you just talk a little bit
more about the general security yeah so
the the Bitcoin network all these
computers around the world that are
doing mining a more accurate description
of what they're doing is actually
they're securing the Bitcoin network so
the more computers that are mining the
more secure the Bitcoin network is and
the Bitcoin network is somewhere on the
order of several thousand times more
powerful now than the world's top 500
supercomputers combined so it's
absolutely an incredible feat of
Engineering yeah wait so how do you get
that kind of computing power like are
there just I assume there's farms of
servers just like it's just someone that
invested in it in a farm right I mean is
that what works and initially it was
just people at home in their bedroom
because you know you if you found a
block you would get a dollar I mean so
it wasn't that excited but now today
when you find a block on the blockchain
you get you know 80,000 plus dollars so
now it's big big business so people have
big giant warehouses filled with tens of
millions of dollars of this mining
equipment using you know tens of
megawatts of a power per per location
and it's a big big business at this
point and you can still do it at home
one of the most important factors though
is the cost of electricity so the
cheaper your electricity is the more
profitable your Bitcoin mining can be so
I assume there's some Bitcoin people
that probably want to go into solar and
move to Nevada or something yep and then
there's people going around looking at
buying power plants and buying
hydroelectric dams and all sorts of
stuff it's really become a worldwide
major industry at this point yeah I
mentioned to you the BNA we're gonna
have to do some definitions here so
blockchain what
is blockchain so blockchain is just a
fancy name for this worldwide ledger
that's kept on everybody's computer
that's running up this copy of the
software and the ledger stays in sync
with every other copy so that's a that's
basically what a blockchain is and the
reason it's called a blockchain is that
ledger it's not updated all the time
it's updated in steps and each step or
update is a block of new information
that's attached and they're all chained
together mathematically so they're all
in order so of a new block gets added to
the end of the blockchain on average
once every 10 minutes and now the the
blockchain is I don't know
coming up on half a million blocks long
and it's been going on for nine years
now something like that yeah what are
most people who use it actually using
Bitcoin for right now like are they
using it mostly just to transfer money
from person to person or I noticed
actually just two days ago I bought
something on overstock.com and it was
the first time that I ever saw on an
e-commerce site that I could have paid
in Bitcoin I had actually never seen
that before but what are most people
using Bitcoin for I think it depends
it's kind of like asking what do most
people use money for and it varied up
fair in my book Bitcoin is money so
people use money in different ways some
people save with it some people spend it
some people gamble on the internet with
it some people buy drugs with it some
people do whatever it is they want with
it but in my point of view each each
person owns their own money and they
should be free to do whatever they want
with it so long as they're not
initiating force or fraud against other
people and yeah but I'm curious do you
know it what any of the trends are like
our people really at the moment just
getting into Bitcoin so they can save it
hoping that you know treating it more as
a stock than an actual cash or are they
all right then we can also talk about a
little bit about the split with Bitcoin
cash - that's probably a good Segway to
that but do you have any sense of what
the actual habits are yes I think that's
a great segue into that so when I first
got involved in Bitcoin I was the first
person the entire world to start
investing in Bitcoin startups so my
first step what let's pause there for a
sec so this is 2011 right right what are
a 2011 bitcoins are less than $1 each
okay and what possessed you to get my
kid you see that you were like alright
this is going to be something so um I
grew up in Silicon Valley been playing
with computers since I was a little kid
love computers all the time and my hobby
was studying economics and just kind of
by chance I came
macrosse1 economics book in in junior
high when my mother told me I couldn't
play anymore Nintendo I had to go and do
something else I'd pick up a book off
the shelf and just by luck it was a book
called socialism by Ludwig von Mises and
some people may know who that is and
what that book is and a lot most people
I expect won't and when I picked up that
book I thought it was a pro socialism
book and I didn't really even know what
socialism was but I kind of knew that
Americans were supposed to be opposed to
socialism but I thought you know I
should have an open mind I should at
least hear what the other side of the
the you know this point of view has to
say and it turned out that I think was
the Wall Street Journal referred to look
mom uses his book socialism as looted
von Mises is devastating critique of
socialism and in this book he kind of
points out that prices are incredibly
important and without the pricing
mechanism you don't know what raw
resources should be used to produce what
consumer goods so this you my glass of
water here is made of glass that I don't
know how I don't even know how they make
the glass but I guess some sand and they
melt it down or something like that but
without the price we got it from Target
for the record so we spare no expense
around here you know everything right
and with the prices that go into the
sand and then the factory and this and
that they know that maybe they should
make glasses out of sand rather than
glasses out of gold or glasses out of
copper or take your pick and so all the
prices all over the world allocate all
of these resources and all of these
companies and all these factories and
people and individuals all the way to
the time when you get to Target and you
look at the different glasses there and
you think this one's glass this one's
plastic this one suits my need better
than this one and this one cost this
much and it allocates the resources of
the entire world without a pricing
mechanism you have no idea what raw
resources should be used to create what
consumer goods and reading this book was
like wow any time the government gets
involved in any area of the economy
they're causing a misallocation of
resources and resources are being
diverted from their most economically
efficient use to something that's less
economically efficient and saying
something's less economically efficient
is just a fancier way of saying you're
making the world a poorer place than it
otherwise would have been and so I found
these ideas incredibly interesting if I
it gave me a better understanding of the
world and so I read one economics book
after another after another half
or another and so I I got to read these
theories about the origin of money and
what the origin of money is and the idea
if the origin of money is that it starts
out as a commodity but not just any
commodity it has to be commodity that's
easily recognizable easily divisible
easily transportable you can store it
easily for a long time and it won't you
know go mouldy or disappear and it has
to have these certain characteristics
that make something as money and I read
about these theories in the books and I
was pretty convinced by the theories and
not to go down a whole other tangent but
I actually did some time in federal
prison in the US as well and when I was
in Federal I've got it noted right there
okay while I was in federal prison I got
to see firsthand in this micro prison
economy that sure enough the theories in
the books that I had read about the
origin of money were true and practiced
so I got to see within the prison that
sure enough people are using commodities
as money so in prison people use tobacco
and postage stamps and top ramen soups
as money because all of those things are
easily storable easily transportable
easily divisible easily recognizable and
of course the limited supply is
important as well and so I got to see
firsthand before my eyes that the
theories that I had read about in the
books are actually true in practice and
then Bitcoin came along and I saw
Bitcoin and I knew from the theories in
the books and from the practical
experience and the empirical evidence I
had from in the prison economy I knew
people were gonna start using it as
money and because the supply of Bitcoin
was limited and I knew people were gonna
start using it as money that meant the
price of Bitcoin in terms of dollars
would have to go up so my first step was
to buy a bunch of Bitcoin and my next
step was to start build a that's that or
srted Row but at that early stage when
you say alright I'm gonna buy Bitcoin
who you actually been buying it from
then so this was a I think February of
2011 and so there wasn't really an easy
way to buy Bitcoin at that point there
was no there was no coin base there was
a there wasn't much of anything other
than this one company called mount Cox
and it wasn't really much of a company
at that point so I sent my first wire to
a person's personal bank account a guy
named Jed McCaleb
- his personal bank account in New York
and I got my first bitcoins there and
then in parallel I was trying to buy
bitcoins from another guy off the
internet for anybody who's been around
in Bitcoin for a while they may have
seen the physical cuz he has Bitcoin so
the guy behind that was also nice enough
to send me some bitcoins yeah and so at
one time there was actually a physical
there still are they're more of a
collector's item price point and
basically it's a physical coin with a
hologram and when you peel a hologram
off you can see that it's been tampered
with and underneath the hologram is the
magic number that's required to actually
spend the bitcoins did they stop so they
still do make those or maybe someone
somewhere still making them but it was
the reason just because at the beginning
people needed some sort of physical
representation just to kind of
understand I think the main reason is it
made it easier for people to get a hold
of bitcoins so one of the main things
that I did that really helped spread a
Bitcoin adoption in the early days in
2012 I think it was when bitcoins were
like 3 bucks each I started selling
these physical bitcoins and I accepted
credit cards and PayPal and I would ship
them via FedEx we had proof of delivery
so it made it hard for people to do to
credit card charge back so that sort of
thing and we sold thousands and
thousands of these physical bitcoins to
people all over the world that way and
it was an easy way for people to get
their first Bitcoin because then they
could peel off the sticker and redeem
them onto their computer or do whatever
they wanted with them from there and
today they're they're quite the
collector's items because there's not
too many left of those early cause I see
it sell physical bitcoins right so okay
so you you make this initial investment
2011-2012 when did you start to realize
that this really was becoming something
and as we speak right now it's Bitcoin
is basically at its highest value of all
all time in effect yeah I I knew from
from day one once I put together the
pieces in my mind and I understood that
Bitcoin couldn't be shut down or stopped
or controlled in any way and that
there's a limited supply I was so
excited about this that I heard about it
as I was eating breakfast at around 10
a.m. with the full intent of going into
my office that day didn't make it I
stayed home and read about Bitcoin all
day I stayed up all night the next day
and talked around 4:00 p.m. the next day
and I got too tired and I fell asleep
for only about an hour and then woke up
again and
all about Bitcoin and I went on sleeping
maybe an hour and a half per night for
about a whole week Wow
until I got so sick from lack of sleep I
had to call my friends to help me I'm so
sick didn't he he came and picked me up
and drove me to the hospital and they
gave me some sort of a sedative or
something and I passed out of sleep for
maybe 12 or 16 hours either but then
woke up again and it was all Bitcoin and
here we are about seven years later and
it's been all Bitcoin all day every day
for seven years now because this is
literally it's one of the most important
inventions in the entire history of
humankind right up there on par with the
importance of the invention of the wheel
or the electricity or the transistor
that's how big of a deal the invention
of Bitcoin is so I want to get into that
and how it can sort of why you really
believe this can change the way we deal
with borders and societies and Nations
and Wars and and all of this but but
let's just circle back quickly to the to
the split this Bitcoin cash Bitcoin
split yep so when I first got excited
about Bitcoin you could send and receive
any amount of Bitcoin with anyone
anywhere in the world and it was free
most of the time the times it wasn't for
you to pay a fraction of a penny and
that led Bitcoin from being you know
worth almost nothing to this worldwide
phenomenon that it is today but much
more recently within the last year - a
bunch of people that don't have any
background in economics or in business
seem to think that people will use
Bitcoin solely as a store of value even
if it costs tens or hundreds or
thousands of dollars to send Bitcoin
from one person to another and so
they've intentionally undermined because
usefulness in commerce so Bitcoin on
August first split into two versions a
Bitcoin there's now Bitcoin segments and
Bitcoin cash the Bitcoin cash version of
Bitcoin still has fees of less than a
penny you can send receive them with
anyone anywhere in the world just like
that bitcoin segment now the average fee
is about ten dollars I did a Bitcoin
transaction on the way here in fact I
was in sending my Bitcoin Segway
bitcoins to a Bitcoin exchange to buy
more Bitcoin cash bitcoins the fee for
me I send those bitcoins from my
computer to the Bitcoin exchange with
$100 and so if you ask yourself you have
two versions of Bitcoin one is slow
expensive and unreliable
poins egg wit and you have another
version of Bitcoin that's super fast
reliable and cheap it's not a type to
see it and that's Bitcoin cash it's not
a tough decision as to which one people
are gonna start using in commerce but
these are right so I might I might be a
little confused here so when I'm telling
you that I have two and a half Bitcoin I
when you say big coin Segway that's the
original the original so to speak right
well so that's debatable as well so it
depending on when you received those
two-and-a-half bitcoins it was probably
from a bunch of people at our time
however many bitcoins you had on August
1st of this year you now have that many
Bitcoin cash as well so let's say you
had two bitcoins exactly on August 1st
you now have two bitcoins and two
bitcoin cash although I believe you said
that you were holding your bitcoins on
coinbase I did and as we were talking
about before the show
yeah I'm bass is a fantastic company but
it's not a Bitcoin wallet it's a Bitcoin
bank and they're holding the bitcoins on
your behalf and now they're holding the
Bitcoin cash on your behalf and so
you're gonna have to wait for them to
get around to giving you access to their
Bitcoin cash which I think they will but
if you were using a Bitcoin wallet in
which you're holding the bitcoins
yourself on your own device you would
have access to your Bitcoin cash right
there from day one so what do you mean I
don't have access to it if I was to
right now login and I got to do all that
stuff on my phone and all the password
craziness and all that I'm very happy
that you have to do all those things
obviously what do you mean I don't have
access to it you only have access to the
Bitcoin segment version of Bitcoin base
today they've promised to give everybody
access to their Bitcoin cash at some
point and hopefully they'll do that
sooner rather than later but August 1st
was a couple of months ago now and they
still haven't gotten around to doing it
and I'm confident that they will um but
it's nice to have access to your money
now and not have to wait around for
somebody else to do it that's why it's
very important and I always tell people
use a Bitcoin wallet not a Bitcoin bank
so why wouldn't everyone want Bitcoin
cash though unless I'm missing I think
everyone is going to want Bitcoin cash
this won't work so then what the logic
yeah what's the reason you're not using
it yet is that this Bitcoin separate
version of Bitcoin managed to bring
along all of the existing infrastructure
in Bitcoin that's been around for you
know nine years now eight years now
Bitcoin cash has only been around a
couple of months since August first and
the fact that Bitcoin
cash is now supported on the Bitcoin
comm wallet it's supported in the
blockchain dot info wallet coin bases
publicly said they're going to support
it it's supported in the bitpay wallet
it's getting more and more support from
wallets and merchants processors and
exchanges I think it's a matter of time
and people are faced between a fast
cheap and reliable version of Bitcoin
and a super slow and expensive and
unreliable version of Bitcoin right
there that's the argument from the slow
people the people that don't agree with
you on this what's the actual argument
if we're really just talking about slow
speeds and sure clunkier process
obviously that doesn't sound good
so to have fast cheap reliable
transactions on Bitcoin it requires a
more expensive computer to run a full
node but the vast vast vast majority of
Bitcoin users aren't running a full node
anyhow you've probably never run a full
node in your entire life and nobody you
know none of these coinbase users are
running a full node coinbase runs a
number of full nodes to support european
transactions so if you have the Bitcoin
cache version will require bigger blocks
which require a more powerful CPU and
more storage space so right now today
you can run a Bitcoin full node for the
Bitcoin segment version literally on a
twenty five dollar raspberry pi these
people are ready what is that no a
Raspberry Pi is a twenty five dollar
computer yeah the name of the computer
that's there's a yeah there's an actual
complete other thing I'm PI's now but
wait there's a computer called the
Raspberry Pi yes well I like the number
lacked god no you see there's a lot of
yeah you know we're running this thing
on cakes okay so you can run the Bitcoin
segment version of Bitcoin on a twenty
five dollar computer Bitcoin cash today
can still run under twenty five dollar
computer but in the future as Bitcoin
cash becomes more popular maybe it'll
take a hundred dollar computer or even a
five hundred or even a thousand or a
couple thousand dollar computer at some
at some point but that's okay most
people aren't running full nodes anyhow
and if you're if you cost five or ten or
a hundred dollars to use Bitcoin it's
eggwin and it costs a penny to use
Bitcoin cash it's clear so you have you
been accepting donations on your website
I think you got most of those donations
before the price of Bitcoin transactions
skyrocketed and the reason the price of
Bitcoin Segway transactions
skyrocket is there's one megabyte worth
of transactions that can happen each
10-minute period that can hold about
2,000 Bitcoin transaction
in the early days maybe ten people were
using Bitcoin every 10 minutes so you
could do it for fur in your transaction
will be included now that bitcoin is
this worldwide phenomenon more than two
thousand people are trying to use
bitcoin every 10 minutes but you want
your transaction to be included in the
blockchain so if more than 2000 people
are trying to use every ten minutes they
have to bid against each other and the
top bidders are the ones that are
included in the next block on the
blockchain so now the fees are about $10
per per transaction because anybody that
pays $9 bid by the people that are
paying $10 so Bitcoin caches solution to
that as well just make the blocks bigger
than one megabyte it's 2017 of a
terabyte hard drive is about a hundred
bucks at the moment and they're only
gonna get cheaper year after year yeah
so you're feeling basically is that the
technology will always sort of the
computing power that we need for this
will always sort of stay in front of the
problems right so because it keeps
getting faster there's this great thing
called Moore's Law which is exactly that
that computing power doubles about every
18 months
and so if 8 terabyte hard drive today is
$100 in a year and a half from now it's
gonna be about $50 and then a year after
after that you know $25 and before you
know it they're garbage in the landfill
and people laugh at a 8 terabyte hard
drive the same way we'd laugh about 8
megabyte hard drive today but I remember
8 megabyte hard drives and I remember
when they were several hundred dollars
and I'm not that old of a guy Sam is
gonna continue to happen with computers
before we know it
you mentioned Nintendo before I remember
when the first I think it was 4 megabyte
game came out on Sega Genesis big desire
and they were going people were going
completely bananas about it that is yeah
many lifetimes ago just real quick let's
circle back to this to this wallet verse
Bank thing because I think maybe maybe I
could be a little clearer on what you're
saying so coin base as a bank is really
just holding my Bitcoin if they were if
I had this in a wallet then that's
actually part of the actual blockchain
right if you have it in a Bitcoin wallet
you're interfacing directly with the
actual Bitcoin network whereas when you
use a Bitcoin Bank like coinbase you're
interfacing with coinbase and you're
saying please broadcast my transaction
to the Bitcoin network and most of the
time they do but like your Bitcoin cash
at the moment you don't have access to
it and I would actually recommend it on
your website you should put a Bitcoin
cash address up there
right now if people want to tip you in
Bitcoin it's gonna cost them five or ten
dollars in network fee so if they wanted
to give you a dollar mm-hmm in Bitcoin
they're gonna have to pay six or eleven
dollars to do that and I don't think too
many people are gonna do that it would
seem like the type of people that would
make sense to whereas if they wanted to
tip you in Bitcoin cash a dollar they'll
have to send a dollar in a penny and
that's very tolerable to people and I'm
more than happy after we record I can
show ya when cash well I'm gonna say
yeah I've got my own farm out there
servers and we're gonna fiddle around as
he would come up with so then why would
someone use a bank then I think they
just didn't understand the difference
it's just like yourself I think you
didn't realize the difference between
coinbase and a real Bitcoin wallet yeah
until now
fascinating all right well I think we
did a pretty decent job there of the
little stuff do you feel like we
basically got the one am I missing
something on the one on it yeah or
anybody that feels like they're missing
anything on the 101 go go to Bitcoin ,
I'm a little bit biased that's my
website but a fantastic resource get a
Bitcoin wallet and start using it it's
like email if you'd never actually used
email and you only heard people discuss
it right so it would seem hard but once
you used it it's easy it's the same with
Bitcoin so go and actually use it and
and use it with Bitcoin cash because it
won't cost you five dollars each time
you use it it'll cost you a less than a
penny each I'm you make a transaction
all right so the part of this so
shifting from all that the part of this
that I thought was really interesting
beyond just the financial discussion and
just sort of the way that the future of
commerce is gonna work and all that is
you really believe that Bitcoin can
change the way government's act the way
the way we as individuals respond to and
and talk to our governments and all of
that so I'm giving you sort of a broad
question there but tell me about that I
I hear people asking me all the time all
aren't government's going to regulate
Bitcoin and what about government
regulation a Bitcoin but I think they're
asking the wrong question and the real
the real end game here is isn't that
governments are going to regulate
Bitcoin Bitcoin is going to regulate
governments Bitcoin is going to limit
the power that every government on the
planet has to control people look what
happened a few years ago in Cyprus where
every single person there had you know a
big percentage of their bank account
just completely wiped out
Bitcoin gives the ability to people to
opt out of that sort of system in the
United States here you know the
government can print as much money it
anytime for any reason and you better
believe that they're doing that all the
time if you're using Bitcoin that sort
of thing can't happen and one of these
really interesting ideas that did never
occur to me when I was you know going on
my binge of reading economics books as a
kid was a by Milton Friedman and he
pointed out the idea of bracket creep
and the government inflates the currency
every single year so maybe you have you
know two or three percent inflation and
you know year one year to the next
that's not that big of a deal but
compounded year after year after year
before you know it a hundred thousand
dollars isn't you know in ten or twenty
years from now it's not going to be that
big of an income right but the
government tax brackets are likely to
stay about the same so maybe fifty
thousand dollar income today is the
equivalent of a hundred thousand dollar
you can get your income after however
many years it takes to compound to that
so instead of being in a you know twenty
five percent tax bracket you're gonna be
in a forty five percent tax bracket even
though you're not actually earning any
more money each year Bitcoin is the
exact opposite of that there's no
central authority that can make more
bitcoins out of thin air unlike the US
dollar so that's a really powerful way
of people to opt out of this government
inflation racket that they had that they
used to bump everybody into higher tax
brackets year after year right so it's
sort of it's kind of hard to picture
what this would actually look like in
the future but if you if everything
you're predicting and would like to
happen happened in effect as the years
go by people will obviously be buying
more bitcoin using the US dollar in
whatever country are there in whatever
their currency is they're gonna use that
less and that that vary by just doing
that the government's will in effect
have less control over the people
because all of your all of your
interactions all of your exchanges will
have nothing to do with the government
you can see em grinning from some what
is this why is in Bitcoin illegal in
China or they just changed something or
wasn't there something just changed
they've changed a lot of things in in
China at the moment but at the end of
the day it doesn't matter if you have
access to the Internet you can use
Bitcoin and this is really really really
exciting
and I guess it's worth pointing out too
like I wasn't born a libertarian I
wasn't even I didn't really have any
political views at all it was the more
economics I studied the more of a
libertarian I became
and then it was kind of really
depressing as I looked around the world
and governments are manipulating the
economy in all these ways that are
preventing their slowing down the entire
world's rate of economic growth and you
you know if you have economic growth of
you know you know two or three or four
percent per year from one year to the
next that's not that big of a deal but
compounded year after year after year it
really makes a huge huge difference and
so even if the government's just slowing
down the rate of economic growth by just
one percent and I think it's
substantially more than that compound
that times a hundred or a couple hundred
years we'd all have flying cars in Space
Station's by now and be living forever
because of little nano technology robots
that can go on our body and fix
everything that's wrong with us and who
doesn't want that sort of thing if you
don't want it don't participate you're
not forced to participate and that's
what we're talking about we're slowing
down the rate of progress of all of
humankind and bitcoin is this incredibly
powerful tool to help speed up that rate
of progress man there's so many
different ways I could go with that so
the the dystopian future part of this
that I guess I would fear is that if if
the government loses control of the
monetary system all the government
control and the only way they can stop
us now is to go after the Internet
wouldn't it stand to reason that
governments would start going after the
Internet they're like literally the
Internet itself like actually try to
disconnect the internet may whatever
them but lots of governments are
dependent on on the Internet as well but
there's lots also lots of smart people
that are building these mesh networks in
which it's not work it's not dependent
on the same sort of centralized
infrastructure that allow the internet
today and those technologies are only
gonna get more and more powerful and
cheaper and cheaper and cheaper thanks
to Moore's law and before we know it
we'll all be able to connect with
everybody else and we won't be dependent
on you know these big eyes peas and how
do they go about doing that like a mesh
network like that so basically in effect
getting us off Google and Verizon and
whatever else right like that those
won't be the only pathways how do these
guys get out of that system um well I
think we're of a similar age and I'm
sure both of us remember before there
were smart phones and before there were
iPhones and before they were Siri and
Google and all these things and and now
you'd have the entire database of human
knowledge right in your hand
and if you buy a used iPhone you can get
it for about a hundred bucks yeah and
another couple of years that's gonna be
you can buy a cheap Android phone for 20
bucks right now like that's incredible
so the hardware to do this is gonna get
cheaper and cheaper the technology is
gonna become more and more accessible
it's gonna be cheaper and cheaper for
anybody to put satellites up in space
and maybe governments are gonna try and
stop this and do do bad things to do
that but if they start trying to shut
down the world's Internet to prevent
people from using their own money but
that's just a fantastic example that the
government people are the bad people and
they're not our friends and they're not
here to help us anybody that's here
trying to say hey we're gonna turn off
the internet if you use money without
our permission those are bad people we
shouldn't support them we shouldn't want
anything to do with them and that's just
more proof that we do need a Bitcoin to
opt out of there they're violent
coercive system to control us all we
shouldn't be there tax cattle right it's
a right stock yeah it's a great seller
for libertarianism in general like if I
mean this is why I'm always you know
selling the ideas of freedom it's like
if you think people everyone complains
the government's horrible all the time
yet half the people want to give them
more money and give them more control
and it's like no did the opposite yeah
you don't ya starve them but let's try
it let's try it that way so I think I'm
following all the logic here so when you
talk about how why this would basically
stop Wars - do you mean because of
economic reasons or because basically we
wouldn't be giving the economic reasons
meaning countries wouldn't have an
economic incentive to fight but also
that the people wouldn't be giving them
enough money to fight in the first place
is that so there's a couple of reasons
and since we have quite the big audience
I've never talked about one of them
publicly really up until now about that
one - all right let's roll one of the
one of the easy simple reasons is that
lots of governments fund their wars the
inflation they just print money and they
use that money to buy guns and bombs and
tanks and they use it to murder people
all over the world and war is just too
euphemism for murder
you're killing sometimes some bad people
get killed but for the most part
innocent civilians are getting killed
all over the world and let's say
somebody came in here and you know stole
my wallet ran off down the street if I
started chasing them down the street and
shooting guns and I I shot a dozen
innocent people that didn't steal my law
I said oh it's okay because I was trying
to get the bad guy who stole my wallet
I would go to jail for being a murderer
for killing all those innocent people so
let's say let's take for granted let's
say Saddam Hussein was a really bad guy
who deserved to
to be killed they murdered more than
half a million Iraqi children to do it
right that's murder you're killing kids
right it doesn't matter how bad of a guy
Saddam Hussein is you don't go and kill
a bunch of kids to get them and that's
exactly what the United States
government did and if any individual did
that trying to catch a common thief you
would go to jail for but for whatever
reason people just have amnesia or a
closed eyes when when governments do the
exact same thing if you're murdering
innocent people you're a murderer and
that's what governments do and they do
it primarily through printing money and
use that to pay people to go and drop
these bombs and guns and tanks and
Bitcoin takes that power away from them
because if the the end game is to have
Bitcoin replace the dollar or place the
euro replace the end and when I'm saying
Bitcoin today I'm referring to Bitcoin
cash to be clear okay but replace all
those things and that takes away
government's abilities to inflate the
currency to pay for all these things and
people maybe sometimes they worry well
what about you know schools and roads
and bridges and hospitals well guess
what people love schools they love
hospitals they love roads and bridges
things that people like people will be
more than willing to pay for voluntarily
I'm not interested in paying to drop
bombs on people in countries I've never
been to and I'm probably never going to
go to and I think 99% of the people out
there in the world also aren't
interested in doing that and for the 1%
that are interested in doing it do that
with your money don't for that
participate right the other really
really interesting way that I've never
ever spoken about publicly up until now
but I think Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
are a big enough part of our society at
this point where I'm not really worried
about the attacks from governments on
them and initially that was my strategy
from day one I wanted to spread Bitcoin
to as many people around the world as
quickly as I possibly could they would
become too big and too widespread to be
shut down so if people are using Bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies to buy you know
their groceries and their diapers and
things like that how can government shut
it down but here's an interesting look
but do you think we've hit that
threshold no yet but we're getting we're
getting pretty darn close to that and at
this point you know there's I don't know
100 something - under something
governments around the world
if one government wants to shut it down
that probably makes other governments
like it even more
I would guess maybe there's a bit of
that this moment china has been cracking
down
quite a bit I would guess Trump in the
US government maybe like Bitcoin a
little bit more now that China doesn't
like it hmm which we could use a little
bit of that leverage with China right
because how much do we owe them in
actual dollars or maybe we can pay them
back in Bitcoin for pennies on the
dollars in the future wants the RMB goes
to nothing because everybody's using
crypto currencies but another really
really interesting thing so let's go
back in time and a bad guy that
everybody agrees upon you know Adolf
Hitler I think pretty much I thought I
could do one show without a Hitler
reference well I'm playing it safe in my
example okay well let's say and I'm sure
you can find people out there that don't
think he was a bad guy but the vast
majority of society
does think he was a bad guy so Adolf
Hitler started doing bad things with
money stolen from people in the form of
taxes and what did the rest of the world
do they started stealing money from
other people in the form of taxes had
kidnapping and slavery in the form of a
draft right and like a lots of people
went voluntarily but I'm sure lots of
people went involuntarily and we should
be clear with our language right the
draft is the moral equivalent of
kidnapping and slavery there are
literally kidnapping people and
enslaving them and sending them off to
some far-off land to fight against their
will and if they don't do that they go
to jail and half the time when they go
out to the Firefly and they get killed
as well so the draft is the moral
equivalent of kidnapping slavery so
Adolph Hitler is a bad guy everybody
agrees with that almost everybody but
then the rest of the governments around
the world start going and doing all this
crazy bad stuff well what would happen
if we had this online anonymous digital
cache in which people could pool their
resources and set up a betting pool and
anybody that correctly predicts the
right day that Adolf Hitler dies I can
anonymously collect this you know
millions of dollars in an anonymous
digital cache that people all chipped in
a buck here in a buck there in ten bucks
here I bet you could have raised a lot
of money for someone to correctly
predict the right day that Adolf Hitler
dies well I mean this is I said
dystopian before now you're going real
dystopia this dystopia is this utopia
right imagine people could have raised
ten million bucks voluntarily from
around the world and Adolf Hitler can't
round up Jews and send them off to the
concentration camps anymore is that a
dystopia or a utopia well it's a u2
right so it's a utopia in this
explanation there's a
Pisa me and I love all these dystopian
movies which is why I can go down this
road in all kinds of different ways
there's a piece that's sort of like wow
you could really end up creating some
insane vigilante system where it's not
just Hitler that's going to be taken out
but any you know anybody that gets
smeared by the media or whatever and
then this is constantly happening to
people that actually don't deserve it so
that would be the dystopian part but in
this part so I've been thinking about
this for more than a decade but since
before Bitcoin and yeah it's scary you
know we don't want to seem you know
Justin Bieber or people like that well
be having bad things happen to happen to
them but on the net you know if you look
in the last century government's
murdered more than a hundred million
people around the world I mean that's a
lot of people so in effect you think it
would cause governments to police
themselves basically to do good things
because they were you know if there's a
basically a ransom on them or right like
that's that's really the idea here it
might do that or it might just make it
too dangerous for governments in the
traditional form that we have today
where they go around and boss people
around and threaten to send them to jail
if they don't obey maybe it'll make that
sort of thing not possible and as a
voluntary just I think all human or
actions should be on a voluntary basis
Starbucks asks me to buy their coffee
they don't tell me to buy their coffee
if I if I decide I don't want to buy
Starbucks coffee nothing bad happens to
me at all but if I decide I don't want
to pay for Obamacare if I was a US
citizen living in the United States I
would go to jail for not doing it if I
think health insurance to Obamacare is a
good idea I'll pay for myself I don't
need to be forced at the point of a
gonner with the threat of being sent to
jail to participate in that sort of
thing and that's what governments are
the very definition of government is a
monopoly on the use of force and they're
forcing people to do things against
their will and if you think forcing
peaceful people to do things against
their will is a bad thing you should be
opposed to the state and I don't know
what the in defect of the invention of
cryptocurrencies will be on governments
but I'm sure it will vastly vastly
vastly limit their power
and that's a great thing for all of
humankind and it liberates the
individual and it speeds up the rate of
economic growth for the world like maybe
there's some scary things that'll happen
but the
the benefits far far far outweigh the
drawbacks yea i SPECT that some people
are probably watching this going wait a
minute wait a minute this guy is just
trying to talk up Bitcoin because he
probably owns a lot of Bitcoin and he'll
talk it up chalk it up talk it up get it
going and then when he feels it's hit
its peak or when he wants to cash out
he'll cash out and then that's that
so there's some truth I own a lot of
Bitcoin and Bitcoin cash becomes really
successful all over the world I'll make
a lot of money I've already made a lot
of money but I've already donated
millions to charity I donated several
hundred thousand dollars to help Ross
Ulbricht get his appeal going and
hopefully get out of prison for those
who don't know yeah Ross Ulbricht is the
person that was a convicted of creating
the Silk Road which was the first online
anonymous marketplace in which people
could buy and sell anything that sole
purpose wasn't to harm other people and
that guy for creating a website now has
a double life sentence plus 40 years he
didn't kill a single person he built a
website and now the government sent him
to jail for two life sentences plus 40
years so his mom would make a fantastic
guest on your show in the future she's
an incredibly wonderful woman and can
you imagine you know if you have kids
imagine your son got sent to jail and
he's gonna die in prison for having
built a website that allows people to
buy and sell things mainly pot is that
what it was well I was gonna say well
would be mainly drugs is what people
were using it for and if you think about
it what are drugs drugs are things that
make people feel happy I mean there's a
bunch of alcohol on the shelf behind me
why is that drug okay pots okay in
California but in the neighboring state
it's not like because a bunch of people
that you and I have never met got
together and wrote down words on a piece
of paper and then call those words a law
writing down words on a piece of paper
and calling a lot doesn't alter morality
either it's perfectly moral for me to a
smoke pot or drink alcohol or smoke
crack or it's not and the politicians
getting together and writing down words
on a piece of paper calling it a law
doesn't alter morality in any way
whatsoever and so this poor young man is
gonna die in prison unless he somehow
gets an appeal or gets out for making a
website that allowed people to buy and
sell these things that make them feel
happy I'm for anybody who's drank some
alcohol or smoked some pot before
they do it because it makes them feel
happy it makes them it improves people's
lives and yeah some people get out of
hand and get addicted and do bad things
but uh that's life you know people die
all the time some people eat greasy
hamburgers and get obese and die of a
heart attack it's their life to do it
with it's not the politicians lives yeah
so you mentioned a second that you were
a citizen of the United States you
actually renounced your citizenship
about what about five years ago 2014 may
4th I'm sorry on February 4th it's one
of the the crowning achievements of my
life I had my only regret is that I
didn't do it sooner okay so you are a
citizen of Japan so I'm not a citizen to
Japan either I'm actually a citizen of a
wonderful country in the Caribbean
called st. Kitts which is probably
country nobody's ever heard of because
there's only about 45,000 people in the
entire country
so wait first why did I think it was
Japan is that I've been living in Japan
for over a decade of Japan's my main
home base Japan's a wonderful country
anybody who hasn't visited there you
were in for a real treat if you go and
visit Japan at some point yeah so so
what caused this decision a couple years
back and why st. kitts well um when I
first got out of federal prison I felt I
had been treated incredibly unfairly by
the United States government for people
that are interested in the details we
can talk about it or Roger maybe really
should maybe real quick we should just
hate on that so why were you impressive
the the short summaries I read all these
economic books and I got really excited
about the power of economic freedom to
make the world a better place and so I
thought the best way to tell more people
about the wonderful benefits of economic
freedom was to run for California State
Assembly as a libertarian candidate so
in the year 2000 I ran for state
assembly as a libertarian I got to have
a debate against the Republican and
Democratic candidates at San Jose State
University and in that debate I called
the ATF and FBI a bunch of jackbooted
thugs and murderers and reference to all
the children that they burnt to death in
a church in Waco Texas and I think 1994
I believe it was I found and maybe their
parents were religious nuts and really
believed in all sorts of magic sky
people and Jesus this and Jesus that
even if their parents were religious
nuts burning to death all the kids
doesn't help them you've murdered a
bunch of kids so if you're somebody that
go
burns to death a bunch of kids in a
church because their parents are
religious nuts you're not a good person
so I called the ATF and FBI agents a
bunch of jackbooted thugs and murderers
in reference to what they did in Waco
Texas back then I still think they're a
bunch of jackbooted thugs or murderers
for what what they did there and not
just that there's plenty of examples but
it turned out there were some
plain-clothed the ATF agents in the
audience and at that point I was torn
deer 21 years old somewhere in that
ballpark and I had already had some
success in business and they really
didn't like the things that this you
know young man was saying and so they
started looking into me and figure out
well how can we prosecute this guy and
so at the time I was selling computer
components on eBay and I was also
selling a product called a pest control
report 2000 on eBay which is basically a
firecracker used by farmers to scare
birds other cornfield and today that
sounds a bit crazy to sell firecrackers
on eBay this was you know in 1999 or so
right this was back when eBay had a guns
and ammo section you could buy ar-15s
and shotguns and ammunition they had a
firework section and it wasn't a big
deal to be selling those sorts of things
so I was selling them on eBay uh for
those are from the Cabela's Sporting
Goods catalog they were selling the
exact same product in their catalog
anybody could order them they'd ship
them to you in the mail this is before
9/11 so it wasn't a big deal back then I
wound up being the only person in the
entire nation to be prosecuted for son
goes without a permit even while I was
imprisoned other companies were still
selling the exact same product without a
permit eventually the manufacturer and
the other resellers were all asked to
stop selling them none of them went to
president them had to pay a fine none of
them had any problem whatsoever I was
the only person in the entire nation to
go to prison or have any problem for
selling them so I I did 10 months in
federal prison had three months of
federal probation the day I was allowed
to leave the country I left the country
I looked into announcing my citizenship
at that time unfortunately it's very
expensive to get citizenship somewhere
else and it's extra difficult if you're
a felon in the United States to get
citizenship somewhere else so I looked
into it at the time there's a lot of
money a lot of work didn't have it as
much money then so I decided I guess
it's good enough to just live outside of
a the u.s. needed to pick a country
wasn't sure where to go I had had one
Japanese girlfriend before in the United
States
was a good experience so uh I figured
there were more to be had in Japan but
if I had had a Russian girlfriend I
would have wound up in a rush or
Brazilian it would have been Brazil it
was just kind of by chance there was
Japan mm-hmm but Harry I'm more than a
decade later and very settled in and you
know speak fluent Japanese at this point
I can give your next interview in
Japanese but why say kids though
ultimately say this is one of the few
countries in the world where you can get
citizenship very quickly by investing in
real estate so I bought some real estate
in st. Kitts visited the island in
person like I love st. Kitts st. Kitts
is a gorgeous place like the low all
years maybe 72 degrees and the high is
maybe 80 85 degrees not very humid
wonderful you weather all year round so
I've been spending every single winter
there that I think this winter will be
by like fourth or fifth year they're
like I'm headed there after LA so it's a
great place and you know go on a if
you're looking for a holiday place go to
st. Kitts I really recommend it yeah
you're on a board of tourism there too
apparently I'm happy to come and say
hello it's a small place in st. Kitts
well now I can obviously understand
after hearing your your story which I
had read about obviously beforehand I
can understand your frustrations of
course with the government and all sorts
of things and that they singled out one
person who all that what was it like
actually that moment when you would
assume you have to sign a couple
documents and what are you doing this
yeah
slap a guy high-five at the end or like
what was that actual moment that's a
great story too so I had to go to the US
Embassy in Barbados and I can't remember
the name of the clerk there but if he
happens to see the interview with like
thank you for being such a good sport
and having a good sense of humor with
all this so I went up to the and you
have to have an interview in order to
renounce your citizenship and one thing
that really surprised me I didn't know
this is you're not telling them that you
want to stop being an American you're
asking for their permission to stop
being an American and I asked the guy at
the window I said have you ever seen
somebody be denied the ability to stop
being American he said oh yeah it
happens all the time
really really was stunning to me I would
have thought that if you don't want to
be an American anymore it should be up
to you but no our masters in Washington
DC decide if they're going to allow you
to stop being an American but this this
clerk at the window when I came up and I
gave my bundle of paperwork
there was a fee the fees even higher now
now the fees 2,000 something dollars
when I renounce I think it was four
hundred and forty dollars and he asked
me said do you want to pay with cash
credit card or Bitcoin and I had the
same look I face that you just didn't I
said what I said how would you know that
I would be interested in paying in bit
Carney said oh we know all about YOU
we've googled you and I said well can I
actually pay him because I was no I was
just kidding so basically you had to
fill out they knew you were coming right
you know so he was just messing with you
kind of he had a good and then uh so you
have the initial interview and he caught
he cautions you he says he warns you he
says and you know I I think the draft is
the moral acquitted kidnapping in
slavery in Wars mass murder
I think taxation is theft you know I
have I'm a voluntary I don't believe in
you know in government and he told me I
said I have to caution you if you stop
being a US citizen you won't be allowed
to serve in the Armed Forces
I thought I'm probably okay with this
and I have to warn you that and so I've
been a felon for 15 years now something
more than 15 years sigh and your as a
felon you're not even allowed to vote
anyhow philosophically I'm not really
interested in voting at this point and
even back then I wasn't really
interested in voting but he told me said
if you were announce your US citizenship
you won't be allowed to vote man he was
just throwing you all the air and
another one so you know at the time I
don't know I was 34 ish I think he said
if you were now it's your US citizenship
you won't be allowed to collect Social
Security and I'm pretty sure that's not
gonna be around by the time I'm old
enough to retire also this was like a
real breakup situation they were they
were pulling out all the stops and he
has his script that he has to cost me
and I think there might have been one
more thing but all of those were like
instead of like oh my god what was I
thinking it was like hurray I can't wait
to be free of Social Security and and
you know there's all this stuff so uh
and so uh it's it's not a decision that
people take lightly either it's a big
big big step in life but they make you
have a one-week cooling-off period so he
cautioned me of all those things and
then I had to hang around for another
week on the island where I don't know
anybody and then went back a week later
and
signed the paperwork and this and that
and uh I was free so that's it yeah
that's it and you did it so now you're a
felon without US citizenship yeah and so
every single time I come into the
country now I get sent to the secondary
inspection and one there is another guy
because ease it on your own oh you don't
have a passport anyway but is there
something on your passport I get if I
get in the u.s. system as you know watch
out for this guy and so another
interesting thing like anybody who's met
me I'm a pretty white collar kind of guy
but since my actual charge is dealing
explosives without a license and it's
worth pointing out that the crime isn't
dealing explosives the crime is doing it
without the license without a permission
slip but that's automatically considered
to be a violent felony so not only am ia
felon I'm a violent felon as well
and so when I can to have a buddy that
would sell firecrackers out of his
basement in high school now in common
when we were probably in you know in the
90s were on high school I think so but I
get flagged on their computer and they
go watch out for this case they sent me
to the secondary inspection sometimes
they're real uptight about it they're
watching and other times or like what do
you do I said it's old firecrackers and
eBay and they're like oh that oh that
guy that guy but apparently they have
some list of notes about me on their
computer and they have to read all the
past notes about me and then write new
notes about the time that I'm coming
into the list of notes they have to read
about me gets longer every single time I
come into the country so it's a bit of a
burden sounds like an episode of
Seinfeld on crack or something
all right well I think I think we did a
little bit of everything here I wanted
to do the 101 stuff which I know you
know you've talked about many times
before I wanted to get some of your bio
if you had to just to wrap this whole
thing up if you had to predict where
this is all going obviously you're very
hopeful for all this but you know there
is some upside-down stuff I'd you know
we didn't even talk about the the reddit
split and that you know there's some
people that are that you know you've got
your haters and trolls and all that I'll
deal with them don't you send them to me
I'll deal with them fear not but if you
had to give me like a prediction of
where you see all this over the next
couple years what do you think is gonna
happen so a couple hundred years ago if
I told you there's going to be a
separation of church and state you would
think I'm a nutcase and a heretic and
I'm
get burnt at the stake for saying such a
thing
before the invention of Bitcoin it would
sound crazy to say that there's going to
be a separation of money and state but
now that doesn't sound so crazy anymore
and it's starting to happen right before
our eyes and I think within another
couple of decades all currencies are
gonna be on beyond the control of
governments people aren't going to be
using dollars and euros and yen they're
gonna be using Bitcoin Kashinath areum
and Manero and things like that and
that's a wonderful wonderful thing for
all of humankind and just like a
separation of church and state was a
great thing for all of humankind a
separation of money and state is as well
yeah well I gotta tell ya I thoroughly
enjoyed this that you know I find I
always learn a little something when I'm
doing these but I think I learned a lot
here and as I said you know these are
ideas the ideas that I try to put into
this business that I you know I've built
a business here are the same ideas that
I try to talk about on the philosophical
level and now we got to turn these 2.5
into into something major so let's do it
you're officially my business manager or
something now you're my digital
cryptocurrency business matter drive
I'll gladly do that and I'll help you
set up a Bitcoin cash donation address
on your website and I'm sure people
would love to send you tips in Bitcoin
cash there you go awesome Beau's a
pleasure talking to you and for more on
Roger you can go to Bitcoin comm or
follow him on the Twitter it's at it's
at Roger K beer
[Music]
you